oh boy we've got
a lot to unpack hey everyone i'm abby
sharp
welcome back to abby's kitchen
[Music]
since i've already been asked about this
a lot we're going to be discussing
another
heavily marketed by influencer
supplement the sugar bear hair line
of vitamins but before we do you can
check out my disclaimer here on the
screen
so feel free to pause this video if you
want to read it or check it out in the
description below
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that little bell
so that you never miss out on
a video all right let's get started and
spill the tea on the
toxic truth about sugar bear hair so the
sugar bear vitamin products are a line
of gummy vitamins
marketed heavily by online influencers
and celebs
everyone from the kardashians vanessa
hudgens and emily redakowski
i mean obviously all beautiful women
with really beautiful hair have been
posting about the stuff online
and i'm pretty sure all the pictures
i've seen feature that little blue gummy
like
seductively placed between the
influencers teeth
because i guess that's how we take our
vitamins but anyways
while the brand does offer a women's
multivitamin and sleep formula
in an effort to be concise today you'll
be focusing on the one you've asked me
out the most
which is the sugar bear hair now first
glance the website doesn't seem to
contain any
major suspicious claims other than the
normal aggressive marketing expected
when trying to get people to purchase a
product so let's just start by taking a
look at some of the
major general claims made about the
product taken straight off of their
website
and i'll add in a few of my quick and
dirty thoughts about each
first is that these vitamins do not
contain any hormones
so it will not affect your facial or
body hair
well that's good but i'm not sure how
they can suggest with absolute certainty
that the product will make the hair on
your head grow
but nowhere else i'm not saying that
this is going to cause you to grow a
beard
but i'm also just pointing out that that
should be maybe your first red flag
that maybe the product will also not
make you grow a
long luscious mane either now next is
that there's no gelatin no dairy
no gluten and no side effects so i'm not
sure we can make such a bold statement
about side effects
about any supplement even if these are
just natural
vitamins and minerals inside this
company has
no idea what your baseline levels of
these vitamins are
or how they may interact with any
medication you're on
or any pre-existing health conditions
that you may have next
is that the gummies are easy to take and
are gentle on your stomach
fine i mean gummies are generally more
easily tolerated than some of those like
big horse pills for some people and i
don't see any
iron in this which is probably the most
commonly cited source of digestive
discomfort from
a lot of vitamins though i will note
that
some people do find that vitamin c zinc
and folate
can be irritating in the gut in large
amounts so
i don't think that we can say that this
is gentle for everyone
fully across the board next is that the
vitamins work best taken for a minimum
of three months
but best results are over six months so
first of all i don't see any clinical
research that would substantiate these
claims about how long it takes to see
results
there is a statistic on their website
stating that 94
of customers see results after three
months however
we don't know how many people that's
based on or
their research methods or anything else
about this
stat but second that means
a lot of dough i mean a month's worth of
gummies will ring you in at thirty
dollars per bottle
so we're looking at ninety dollars for
three months of use
and 180 dollars for six months of use to
maybe see some kind of hair results for
a lot of people
that's a lot of money to spend on a
product that's debatably
totally useless but we'll get more into
that very soon
lastly they state that results will vary
from person to person
and it's recommended for people aged 13
and older
and anybody who's under 13 should ask a
doctor before use
i mean i definitely appreciate the
disclaimer that results will vary
between individuals as
supplements are often sold as like a
one-size-fits-all kind of gimmick
but i would actually argue that it's
really important for someone of
any age to consult a healthcare
professional before starting any kind of
supplement regime
that suggestion should not be limited to
you know people who are under the age of
13.
just saying all right so now that we've
discussed the product claims
generally i thought we would do more of
a deep dive into the ingredients
in these supplements and of course look
at the science behind the claims as it
relates to hair volume
and growth let's start with the star
ingredient in these vitamins
biotin now let's get our facts straight
here folks
biotin deficiency is associated with
alopecia
and hair loss as are a lot of different
nutrient deficiencies
but a review of the literature on the
use of biotin for hair growth
suggested that unless you have an actual
deficiency
which is most often linked to some sort
of genetic
or underlying health cause and really
uncommon if you have a generally
balanced diet
supplementing with more biotin isn't
going to help your hair
biotin is actually the only b vitamin
that is actually produced
in the body and severe deficiency in
healthy individuals
eating a generally healthy balanced diet
is virtually
non-existent this is not a thing
meanwhile this supplement contains 17
000 of the recommended maximum daily
dose of biotin
17 000 and while biotin thankfully is a
water-soluble vitamin and therefore
you'll likely just pee out excess in the
toilet excess
levels can potentially mess with blood
test results
and that can result in misdiagnosis
so this is definitely why you want to
take up your supplement regime with your
doctor
so yeah we could take a hard pass
on that now what about all the other b
vitamins found in the supplement
well in the case of vitamin b12 and
folate one study found
no significant difference between folate
and b12 levels in patients with hair
loss
and those without we do however have
some limited research suggesting an
association
between b12 and folate deficiency and
premature graying
but i don't think that this is a hair
issue that this supplement even promises
to address
now moving on to our antioxidants
vitamin a c
e d zinc etc so first of all
it is true that getting adequate levels
of antioxidants in the diet
can help to fight free radicals involved
with skin damage
and may also play a role in slowing down
age-related hair loss and graying
there was also one very small study
involving a hair growth supplement
containing vitamin c iron zinc and
biotin
which did seem to help improve some hair
growth
but it's hard to draw conclusions from
studies like these
because the composition of these
nutritional supplements are not
disclosed
another super small study found that
vitamin c helped promote hair growth
but the author suggested that this was
likely due to
the vitamin c's role in increasing iron
absorption
and that would help mitigate hair loss
associated with iron deficiency
it's also true that vitamin c plays a
role in helping the body develop
collagen and collagen is an important
protein found in hair
but the research on collagen itself for
hair is even very limited
one industry-funded randomized control
trial found that 15 women with
self-perceived thinning hair
who were given a collagen supplement
experienced subjective
improvements in hair volume sculpt
coverage and thickness
after 90 days but again not only is this
evidence
pretty weak on its own but it's also
assuming that
vitamin c supplementation alone will
yield similar outcomes
it's like saying that a aka vitamin c
is important for c healthy hair when we
really
only know that b collagen is important
for c
healthy hair it's skipping a vital step
here
then there's vitamin a now what's
interesting about the website specific
call out that vitamin a increases sebum
or
oil production in the scalp is that
research suggests that
vitamin a supplementation may actually
reduce sebum production and is therefore
often
used for the treatment of acne for
example one study found that there was a
90 or greater reduction in sebum
levels after six weeks of
supplementation
that's pretty significant and really
unusual considering that
this piece of evidence completely
negates the claims
about vitamin a on the sugar bear hair
website
not only is supplementation generally
unnecessary because
these nutrients are usually found in
amount
in a balanced diet but in the case of
vitamin a
studies suggest that over
supplementation can actually cause
hair loss so yeah
that's not what you want as for the rest
while the rationale for vitamin e
is likely also based on deficiency
symptoms where
low levels of vitamin e have been linked
to
alopecia ditto for things like vitamin d
and zinc so what does this all mean well
here's the truth companies like sugar
bear and so many other
supplement companies rely on small
truths or little
bits of research exclusively found in
vitro
and then extrapolate this to make major
claims
about the human body like growing
beautiful thick hair
so for example sure one of the
physiological roles of vitamin b6
is for red blood cell formation and
increased blood flow
is important for stimulating hair growth
but how does this play out
in real life from taking a gummy
supplement and how much do you
actually need to make an impact not to
mention
99.99999 of this alleged evidence
is very clearly correlation based and
not causation
most of the significant benefits we see
in the literature when it comes to
taking supplemental vitamins for
something like hair
happen when correcting a deficiency but
if you're getting a varied diet
it's very possible that the top up in a
supplement
will do really little for the cause so
i'm gonna say it one more time for the
people in the back
if you're not deficient in these
vitamins you likely don't
need to be taking more of these vitamins
to help
improve your hair so how the heck can
sugar bear get away with making some of
these claims well first of all
it says right on their website and i
quote that the statements have not been
evaluated by the food and drug
administration
the fda this product is not intended to
diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease the
views and nutritional advice expressed
by sugar bear hair
are not intended to be a substitute for
conventional medical service
if you have a severe medical condition
see your physician of choice
individual results may vary that
statement there
is actually not atypical so that doesn't
mean that this is a bad product at
all the reality is that the supplement
world is
kind of the wild west in fact in the
united states at least where sugar bear
hair is sold
supplement companies can say almost
whatever they want about a product
my rd colleague rosie schwartz actually
reached out to the fda
to inquire about some of the evidence
used to obtain
marketing approval for supplements not
unlike these
and press officer lindsey meyer said
that the fda
does not require any scientific evidence
to be submitted
according to the fda a supplement
company can make
any claim as long as it's within the
scope of what the human body
can do shorts quoted meyer saying since
hair growth is a natural human function
you can make the claim the supplement
promotes hair growth
but you cannot include a claim about any
treatment
such as the product can be used to treat
alopecia
so to sum that up you can make any
supplement you want
claim it will do amazing things with no
evidence to back that
up as long as it does not treat a
specific
condition yeah so does that make these
unsafe not necessarily but it's
important to note that a lot of
supplements are not well regulated
and therefore can contain contaminants
and while the website does state that
this product is third party tested which
is
definitely what you want to look for it
doesn't mention
by whom or where so when in doubt you
can always check your supplement status
by looking them up on a third-party
testing website like labdoor.com
now the other thing i will quickly
mention is that while i love gummy
vitamins and i take them myself and my
son takes them
you do want to be mindful of how many
you take
unlike those like really big horse pills
it's actually really easy to
overeat and like pop them back like
candy so just know that these are not
meant to be eaten
like candy and you should not exceed the
recommended dose
just because they taste really great
thankfully the one nutrient that this
supplement does go overboard on
biotin is generally benign
the likely worst that could happen with
this supplement
is that you pee out all the excess
pissing away
i guess a bunch of money and maybe it
messes with
some of your blood work numbers so of
course this again
is why it's always really important that
your health care provider
is in the loop on your supplement regime
so in summary the sugar bear hair
products
aren't likely harmful for most healthy
adults besides the assault they may do
on your wallet
but it's also not likely necessary or
helpful
unless you have an actual nutrient
deficiency and resulting hair loss
and like we already established most of
these vitamins in the supplement
especially its star ingredient biotin
are nutrients that
most of us get in abundance anyway so
if you are experiencing legitimate hair
loss and not like
hey my hair is naturally not as thick
and as gorgeous as a celebrity wearing
extensions
then it is best to speak to your doctor
to rule out a bigger problem things like
thyroid disease anemia
protein deficiency malnutrition alopecia
and anxiety are all legitimate health
issues
related to hair loss and these should be
thoroughly ruled out and treated by your
medical team
not self-diagnosed or self-treated with
a gummy vitamin
and on that note that is all for today
folks if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with any
influencer backed wellness products that
you've
got questions about i'm sure there's so
many of them
um also subscribe to the channel and i
will see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye